benjamin lucas porte parole de
générations bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors
hausse des enquêtes en de l'igpn
notamment en ce qui concerne les
violences policières
la police des polices donc plus saisi en
2019 qu'en 2018 qu'est-ce que ça arrive
à être selon vous ça révèle qu'il ya un
problème est que le problème est sérieux
et que le gouvernement le préfet
nettement le mini-jeu de l'intermission
castaner voir sortir du déni de réalité
dans lequel ils sont arrêtés de se
comporter comme les porte paroles de
certains syndicats de police et et agir
parce que la confiance dans la police de
la république c'est la condition de
notre cohésion nationale la condition de
notre cohésion républicaine
et que tant qu'il y aura des centaines
de milliers de nos concitoyens qui
sortiront dans la rue avec la trouille
aux ventes de croiser même que leur
entreprise la police ça révélerait un
grand problème un grave
dysfonctionnement de notre république
alors il ya ce rapport de l'igpn ya
celui du défenseur des droits
jacques toubon assure avoir demandé des
sanctions aux sites qu'ils ne viennent
pas cela va donc plus loin que la police
qui se comporteraient mal on parle là
d'une police qui seraient protégés en
tout cas dans certains cas précis
oui ça démontre qu'une forme d'omerta je
le disais il ya un déni de réalité de la
part des autorités sur ce sur ce sujet
pourtant la peur de la police pour
beaucoup de nos concitoyens les réelles
pourtant la question du racisme est
réelle la question des contrôles au
faciès de défenseur des droits votre
site et il dit que la raison de la
couleur de sa peau vous pouvez être
contrôlé deux fois plus qu'un autre
est-ce que nous pouvons accepter ça dans
notre notre république donc oui il ya
une forme d'omerta une forme de déni
institutionnel sur ce sujet or bien il
n'y a pas de république possible sans
police républicaine et donc il faut agir
et l'egypte vite en fait aujourd'hui
dorée de problèmes avec la police
française si je peux dire le problème
des habits policiers et le problème du
racisme oui et souvent souvent les deux
sont liés aux je crois qu'il ya dans le
racisme
une brutalité et évidemment ces deux
problèmes là doivent être traitées de
front il faut une attestation de
contrôle d'identité pour lutter contre
les contrôles au faciès
il faut de meilleurs sanction des
enquêtes plus indépendante et plus
rapide des sanctions plus fermes
ça a été rappelé par un défenseur des
droits en
en cas de violence met tous à partir
d'un même ensemble qui est je crois
aussi une forme de d'absence de volonté
politique de s'en prendre à ce que sont
des problèmes et qui permettrait
d'ailleurs c'est pour les policiers
aussi pour tous les policiers qui font
correctement leur travail dans le
respect des règles de la république dans
le respect de la promesse républicaine
d'égalité
pour eux il faut rétablir la confiance
aussi donc pour ça il faut sanctionner
plus durement plus fermement les actes
de racisme ou de violences policières
qui sont nombreux qui sont une réalité
aujourd'hui dans la police vous parlez
des contrôles au faciès ça fait
longtemps qu'on en parle qu'on parle
certains problèmes au sein de la police
française
pourquoi ça met autant de temps à
évoluer pourquoi on n'en est pas encore
à un moment où les politiques ont pris
vraiment le problème à bras le corps
parce que je crois que le jeu disait que
ministre de l'intérieur se comporte
comme le porte parole du syndicat
alliance n'est pas comme le ministre
l'intérieur peut-être aussi une peur
électorale 54% des policiers ont voté
pour marine le pen au premier tour la
dernière élection présidentielle ça
démontre aussi une forme de morosité en
tout cas de pénétration de l'extrême
droite dans la police tout ça devrait
inciter plutôt que d'être sur la retenue
d'être dans le délit d'être finalement
dans la discrétion de la part des
autorités à prendre le problème à bras
le corps y compris je le disais pour
aider celles et ceux qui font
correctement leur métier dans la police
républicaine il y en a beaucoup
forte heureusement à pouvoir le faire
dans de bonnes conditions avec la
confiance de leurs concitoyens alors le
rapport population police est délicate
compliquée rapports parfois on peut dans
certains cas pourquoi pourquoi les
forces de l'anp censés nous protéger
assuré nos sécurités sont ils sont elles
c'est mal perçu dans certains cas et
justement parce que les exemples se
succèdent de violence de brutalité de
contrôle arbitraire de contrôle au
faciès de racisme est donc tout ça nuit
à évidemment au lien de confiance qui
est indispensable parce que la police
elle est censée nous protéger toutes et
tous et je le rappelle ce chiffre il est
édifiant quand même comment peut-on
accepter que quelqu'un soit contrôlée 20
fois plus qu'un autre à raison de la
couleur de sa peau c'est pas l'idée
qu'on sait de la république ce n'est pas
compatible avec et avec nos valeurs donc
évidemment quand ceux ci existent comme
vous avez cette réalité-là cette
violence-là qui s'exprime dans dans la
police et dans les contrôles de police
évidemment que la confiance elle est
rompue mais j'allais dire la confiance
elle peut être rétablie encore une fois
il suffit
il s'agit de volonté politique et
d'action est là mais il faut que
le président de la république pour
communiste mise de l'intérieur se
saisisse du sujet et ça commence par
reconnaître qu'il ya un problème et
c'est quand même la tuque depuis des
semaines depuis des jours
on constate quand même qu'à une espèce
de fermeture complète des oreilles et
des yeux de la part du pouvoir à ce
qu'est la réalité aujourd'hui du lien
entre la police et nos concitoyens merci
beaucoup
benjamin les cas d'avoir été en direct
avec nous sur rt france rappelle que
vous êtes porte parole de générations
merci